Right, just to give you an idea on this talk, it's, it's made-up
as I go. I haven't done it for five
years. So and I'm not I won't run into
the full length. I normally do.
It's I'll try not to because I can do 2 hours on this easy.
When we get going, we're going to do it in an hour.
So I'll skip things. I have, I think I did this about
four years ago in one of the Sr. s s in France when we had some
bad weather. So if you want to see more of
it, maybe we'll cover it all. You can also just hunt on
YouTube for what a thermal looks like my name and you'll you'll
see it again. I used to do it a lot in the
guiding days many years ago, and I do 3 or 4 * a year.
I used to find people used to come back and listen to it two
or three times because it's one of those talks that often it
doesn't make sense until you experience the situation.
And then after that, when you hear it, it helps to explain the
situation. And what I want to try and do is
give you an idea of what a thermal really looks like, not
what the textbook says, except it's not what it really looks
like. It's weather, it's made-up, it's
just my impression of what a thermal looks like.
Some of you will have your own impressions, some of you are
better pilots than me, so we've all got our own ideas.
But this was really my struggle in my early days trying to
thermal and not really knowing what to do.
And people would just say if it beeps, turn.
It's works to start, but if you want to be better, you need to
start building up some mental images of things and then
deciding how to how to adapt to that for your flying.
So for sure, these are just ideas.
They're just my ideas. You may have your own
impressions and yeah, we'll have some talks as we go.
So I think with anything in thermaling, you first got to go
backwards for the thermal. It's all right to say the
instruments beeping. Let's turn.
But I think we need to rewind quite a bit to where the
thermal's coming from and things.
So let's see if I can do some bad diagrams with limited
colours. I have no green.
I think it's worth starting first at just the ground, the
basic ground I What do you need for a thermal to resist up
there? What do you need before you
start, before the thermal can exist?
So sun, sun's a good one. That's heat is what's a thermal
is. So the, the sun's required in
here. So the sun's shining down.
What else are we going to need around to get this thing going?
Wind can be triggers. We need triggers.
And yeah, the contrast, which is the sources.
So it's interesting you think about some of this Sahara
desert, it's hot, should be booming with thermals.
It's probably not. It's probably quite stable
because you don't have the contrast.
The contrast in there are quite important.
Temperature doesn't really matter.
You get good thermals in Slovenia.
I can do 100. I live in Slovenia.
You can get good thermals in Slovenia every month of the
year. 100 KS I can do in November, December, January,
every month a year because it's not temperature, it's the
differentials, it's the sources and the triggers.
You need those things to get thermals going, which is why the
Alps is so good. The Alps is full of
differentials for us to run through.
A few basics on on here maybe. So we got the ground if we heat
the ground up. So we got an area, ground that's
a bit darker in colour. Imagine the black is grass.
It's probably not far off this year.
It's quite burnt in some areas around here.
And then you got a an area that's the dark area that's
probably going to heat up faster than the surrounding areas.
And that's going to build up our source where the hot air is
going to come from. So as the sun is shining down,
the sun is now red as well. It's shining down, It'll heat up
the ground. Generally, this spot here is
heating faster than the surrounding areas.
So that's the area we're building up.
A nice source. So what sort of things?
Just namely a few random things, What would you expect to be a
good source in most of this talk?
I'm thinking of Alpine areas, but you expand it into
flatlands. Spain.
But yeah. So what was that one they had
gravel. Yeah, gravel.
Throw them out. There's hundreds of things.
Rocks are good, concrete can be. That's all pretty hard.
Solid substances so far. But yeah, brownfields, that's
probably the most classic things we're going to meet when we're
flying is the, the the plowed fields, brownfields and things.
Anything else? It's what power lines.
That's not a source, that's another source.
Actually, the metal I guess would heat up, but it's not a
source as such. That's more of a trigger, which
is a completely different thing. So, but it's, it's basically
look at those differentials. There's dry ground, there's damp
ground. You know, the dry ground's going
to start heating sooner. It's, it's lots of things that
can create sources. So when you're flying, you need
to be looking at that terrain in front of you can see.
And this around here in particular, it's all pretty
bland at the moment, yellowy looking everywhere.
So there's no point just flying in a straight line over the
terrain. You're going to have to just
adapt a little bit for the areas you think are heating up the
best. So the plough fields rather than
the the green fields, not many of them at the moment, but just
considering that terrain, where is the sun heating the best?
So that that's one aspect. Your other aspects might be the
shape of the terrain. So on there you'll probably find
actually I got a pen and you wouldn't use the pen on this
one. Actually you'll probably find
how I've drawn it. But this area is heating the
best because it's facing the sun better.
So angles of terrain also makes a big difference for what's
heating the best and what's creating the best source.
And then from that, let's go back to level.
If we've got this area here that we're considering is the best
parts of all the terrain, just from there to there, the area
it's going to heat up the best, it's then trying to visualize it
mentally again for what's going on in that area.
So for me, it helped me on it. If I visualize that it's a
bubble of warm air there and it's got a skin on it, which it
definitely does not have, but it's got a skin on it and that
bubble of warm air builds up, getting hotter and hotter trying
to release. It's not actually that there's a
skin on it. It's more that the colder air
above it is holding it down. The colder air is more dense and
the the denser, heavier air is trapping the lighter air there
and it just can't release easily.
But for me, just in my mind, it just became easier to think of
it. It's a skin.
It's all a bit trapped there. It can't go.
I like easy systems. So this hot air, it wants to
rise. Now it's got this skin on it for
stopping. It can't go.
So what do we need next to make this all start working?
The triggers. We need the triggers.
So your pylons was 1. So we got a pylon that's
sticking up here, whatever. And in doing so, it bursts the
skin, it splits the skin there. And because of that, now the
warm air starts breaking away coming up and you've, you've got
your source, you've got trigger, you've got a thermal.
So there's a simplistic way of thinking of the ground.
And then for the next level part of it, once it's triggered, this
dense air squeezing our skin, it starts forcing everything to
that area. So you can think of it as it
being sucked out with a loose air, the, the lighter air going
or just this is helping push it out through the, the split in
the, the skin, if you like. So that's a nice simplistic way
a hand went up there. This is what we say, right?
But is there any scientific backing behind it?
Yes and no. I haven't looked at studies, but
I think it's definitely this air is more dense and cooler.
So it's definitely a push on to this and definitely it forms a
type of boundary layer and that's what accelerates it.
Piles that they are. Pylons for me are some of the
best triggers. I suggest not using them on too
close to save, but some of my best climbs have been here.
I had a notable 1. I mean my background.
I've been flying since the beginning of the 90s.
In paragliding my father was Hang Gliding in the 80s.
My father was gliding and parachuting when I was born.
I grew up with aviation and I've I've dabbled in pretty much most
things in this sport. So I've got an Atos.
I fly occasionally, hang gliders, para motors, I've been
around a few and I used to a lot of paramotoring in the UK and
there was an airfield, all green, the worst source in the
world and the slight hill, horrendous.
But I needed to cross it and it's an old military World War 2
airfield. It was huge and there's one
pylon in the middle and if I sat myself on top of that there was
always a thermal. They work, so that's one, but
what other triggers are there? There's far more than pylons, So
what other things would work as a good trigger?
Lakes, if you were sorry, small lakes.
Small lakes. So that's always a good one.
So for those of us from Jamona, where's my cloth gone?
Those of us who are flying in Jamona recently, I don't know.
If you notice, not far from Port Arno, there's a lake around the
corner. And a lot of people just think,
oh, water, no thermals. The lakes can be really good
triggers, not sources, and so when often when you fly just
over the lake's edge, just down wind of the edge, you find that
it there's often a thermal just there.
See how well this cleans off? It's.
Nice because they show the ripples as well, so you see
exactly. Yeah, the water can indicate a
lot, but just having that water here, it often assumes some
wind. So if we get a wind sock in
here, so the wind's blowing this way, the the source here is now
drifting gently with the wind and it pushes up against this
cold lake and it just triggers on the edge there and off goes
the thermal. So lakes could be really good
triggers if you get the right part of the lake.
So that works well. What are the triggers?
We got tractors. Yep, that's one I used to read
in. I don't know if you ever sort of
well heard of Judy Lennon. She was in the 90s, eighties,
90s. She was hang glider and
paraglider, world champion and she wrote a book and her
favorite was tractors. Or how was it as described?
Someone went out flatland flying in Spain and flew 100 kilometres
and all his mates were impressed and asked him how he did it.
He said I just flew tractor to tractor.
It was easy. His mate came back a week later,
said I managed it as well, but I didn't use a single tractor.
Explain that then oh, Sunday there's no tractors out that day
anyway, are tractors. But that actually does lead into
something, things like tractors and things.
It's gives me a little impression of how deep this
bubble might be because for a tractor to burst that skin
tension, it suggests actually this bubbles not that tall, it's
quite close to the ground. Hedges.
You haven't meant just hedges, but hedges could be a good
trigger or trees can be a very good trigger.
Tree lines in particular, all these things are not that tall,
so our source bubble is not necessarily that deep.
So another indicator can help there.
So yeah, we've got in our trees and hedges there.
Anybody else we can Chuck in slope traders terrain changes?
Yeah, that's a brilliant one for me.
So it might be that the terrain lifts up and with that wind
direction, it just triggers on the little terrain change.
But the terrain change could be both directions.
So I used to fly in Azure quite a lot and we used to have
ditches there or just a terrain going down.
And the hot air doesn't like going downhill or across these,
it just triggers. So really triggers can be
anything that's just not that bland area you had.
Anything that's just suddenly different can cause a trigger,
whether it be through shape, through piercing the bubble or
just through colours or something.
And if you've got none of that lot, it can still trigger.
If it is just bland ground, eventually it gets so hot it
will trigger anyway. It'll just be bubbling and
bursting and off it'll eventually go anyway.
Yeah, small towns often actually, though I find towns
can be strange. They can be so convoluted with
triggers and stuff. They're not always the best
towns, but if it's a town then surrounded by the blandiac
trigger, then it does does trigger.
So towns I find a funny one. Big towns can be difficult
finding stuff in. But small towns like in Spain,
or collections of houses, yeah, they're superb triggers, yeah.
Along the sea of cow, the egg. Ah so clouds sucking that's yeah
so the clouds there, I guess they're sucking it's much harder
one to form theories on but disturb it oh oh the shadows.
Sorry the shadows. Sorry.
The shadows, yeah, shadows again.
They're just like the lake. The shadows cold and the edge of
it can trigger again. Yeah, the.
Which which way often see. Yeah.
So, yeah, for sure, as the shadows moving across the gowns,
the edge of the shadow acts as the cold boundary layer and
triggers. That works.
So I mean, we're going on forever, believe me.
There's a lot of sources and triggers out there, but the
basics are just look for those large areas that look like they
were heat. He's trying to record this, He's
got a phone call. Look for those large areas that
will record. I sort of build this the source.
Either look for the differentials on the downwind
side, preferably that will trigger it, or inside it that
will trigger it. And if there's no winds, then
the trigger has to be somewhere within that source to get it to
go. So that's a little bit on
sources and triggers, just really to get you thinking on
those as you go. How you adapt these today like
the other day. Well, yeah, it's too windy to go
into too much detail on this. This is more of your classic
days, this sort of thing. There's just some ideas to get
you thinking really on that. The next one worth looking at a
little bit is the thermal when it's rising and where we should
be positioning ourselves on those thermals.
Where should we dive in? Let's just sort of redraw the
basics of that again. So we've got a thermal bubble.
It triggers whatever you want that's used for a trigger.
So let's just say it's our antenna mass this time.
Again, it triggers when we're thermalling.
Where is the core on that thermal?
You've got a thermal going up, so let's go with our textbook
thermal. They sort of look like that,
apparently, with a cloud on top. That's what they draw in the
textbooks. Typically.
I'll change the shape in a minute because I don't agree
with that shape entirely, but where is the core on this thing?
Is it 1-2 or three? Yeah, it's sort of nearer to why
it's in this area, the core somewhere around there.
But the question is, why is it there?
Why isn't it in the middle? This is of the inertia.
Inertia. OK, let's let's go for another
one then. It's, I don't know, is it?
No, maybe that's a bit much to throw in it.
Let's just start with this one. The core is we generally
appreciate it's on the upwind side near the front of the
cloud. I think we all pretty much
understand that, but it's definitely worth trying to
understand why the mathematicians might get this
faster. The fast part.
The, So it's, it's the, yeah, the hottest air I've probably
got the hottest air goes more vertical.
So I don't know if we can just throw in some numbers for the
sake of it. Let's say the wind is at 1 metre
a second. It's a light wind in the Alps
air. What's the average thermal
strength we get in the sport? In most places we fly, it's
about 2-3 metres a second and that's pretty much the norm
everywhere we go. So if we got a light wind and we
got air that's rising at 3 meters a second, this this air,
it's going up 3 meters, but it will drift 1m with the wind and
it'll go up 3 meters, drift 1m with the wind.
So that hot air is heading at that angle is the first thing.
But in this source, this field's not a perfect field.
It's got a couple of wet puddles in that part.
It's got a little bit of a slope going downhill here.
It's not all heating up to exactly the same temperature in
our bubble. So in our bubble, and I've no
idea real temperatures, I just make them up in the head.
I I would say that there's air in there that's maybe 4° C
hotter than the surrounding area.
There's a little areas that are already 1° C hotter, and then
all of that gets disturbed it it releases, it's got this dead air
pushing everywhere, forcing it out through the broken bit of
skin. And that 4°, I don't know, maybe
it's 8°. Whatever it is, it's rising
quite fast. It's quite warm relative to the
surrounding air. So it goes up 44 meters a
second, because you're 3M a second climb is actually a 4m a
second thermal. We're always falling.
So it rises 4 meters and it drifts with wind 1m.
But this 1° air that's also in the bubble, it also gets pushed
through the hole. But because it's much cooler, it
only rises 1m per second and still drifts 1 and rises 1 and
drifts 1. So it goes off at a shallower
angle as it goes. It's very slow rising air, it's
at the back, the strong rising air's at the front.
And you might even find that this slower rising air
stabilises with the surrounding air much sooner.
So maybe the 1m a second climb stops here, the 2 meter second
climb gets to here, the three gets to here, and the strong
stuff gets the top. That makes sense.
So I think the back of the thermal is more likely to have a
A curve to it like this where the weak stuff just stabilises
and it's very weak and the strong stuff goes all the way to
the top very quickly. I don't know, it all made sense,
but it's basically that's why your strong air is at the front.
It's pushed very vertical without much drift.
The weak stuff's at the back. That all makes sense.
So the next one is then why is it we have to push into the wind
now and again? Why not?
Why not? It's doing constant thermals in
that strong bit of air all the way up.
Should be easy according to that, but it's not easy.
We have to push in to win now and again to stay in the core.
So what's causing that effect? No ideas there's.
It's the falling bit that's doing it that's causing us to to
drift out. So let's see if I can make
enough of a clear board to explain the theory on that.
So it's the air goes up, but the four meters a second, just
backwards 1m a second, and then you fall 1m a second and then it
goes up four backwards one down one.
So the air itself is going to that angle, but you tend to go
off at a shallower angle because of this constant falling up 4
back one, down one. The next problem is now you're
in the three metre a second air. So now you're going up 3, back
one, down 1. And when you've done that a few
times, well now you're in the two metre a second area.
So you gradually just get thrown out of the back if you don't
push into wind now and again. So you have to push into wind a
little bit to counteract where you've been falling, which has
pushed me backwards in the thermal effectively.
And then that'll keep you in the core.
So the stronger the wind, the more you've got to keep pushing
in to stop yourself getting blown backwards.
See if it's a 3 metre, a second wind, you get back here into the
weak stuff much faster. So keep pushing up to into wind.
That makes sense. Stop me if you have any
questions anytime. Right that way.
Is that changing ice with ice? It's great, but it is single day
or the single day or attach yourself.
I've just obviously we're talking weather.
There's a million scenarios, but so, yeah, but the winds, the
stability will affect things for sure.
So I was going to cover a little bit about inversions and stuff
in a minute and how that will change.
I've got another. Question, but I haven't quite
voiced it out there. And so if you've got this bubble
which contains different heated passes of air which aren't going
to mix particularly well together, but they're all very
squeezed out through the same what, presumably then you're
going to have sections of that, but it's not going to be a
continuous 4 metre a second at the front of that line, then be
bits of four metre a second. Yeah, that that's, that gets
into lots of different areas. Like I, I like to say this is an
Alpine torque because the Alps tend to give a fairly constant
feed. The sources aren't switching on
and off. But yeah, if if it's the source
is switching on and off, you know, can it'll get to a point
all the hot air's gone out and the other bits with it that it
has to reheat and switch on or yeah, the hot eggs all
accelerated out. You've got the cooler air.
Eventually it'll just stop releasing for a while until it
re warms up and then go again. So but all of this says just
weather. It's very hard to cover every
scenario. Let's throw in then whip.
You're flying along. You've been left behind 20 KS by
the lead gaggle, so you're completely on your own and
there's no birds or anything, you're just in the sky on your
own. You hit lift, Which way do you
turn? Left or right?
It's the answer generally should always be if you've got no other
information, and usually even if you do have information into
wind, you should always go into wind if you're not sure if we
sort of look down on the thermal.
So looking straight down, you got a big round thermal cloud,
whatever shape it is, and you're just flying randomly along on
your paraglider in this direction.
You hit lift, it started beeping.
It's which way to turn. Because of how we know the wind
direction, we should know that the core in theory is in this
area. It should be on the upwind side
of this bigger thermal area. So by turning into wind, it's
still 5050. It might be you caught just the
front of it, you turn into wind and you got it wrong.
But the beauty of getting it wrong there is when you turn
around, you're going downwind, you're very quickly into the
core. Whereas if you got it wrong on
the back, turn downwind, having met the back you, you very
quickly fall away from it. And now you got to fly into wind
to get to the core. So if you got no other
information, it's always better to turn into wind.
It's usually better, especially, I mean, the only time you fell
out and got it wrong is if you were right at the front.
Whereas if you do it here, you're on the core.
Do it here, you're not on the core, but it's still better than
here. Here, this area's still better.
So you just turn into wind 1st and then you'd often just keep
pushing into wind and it's getting better and better and
better. At some point it's going to
stop. I wouldn't wait until it
stopped. I would just wait until it's got
enough. I'm happy.
So if I'm pretty close to base anyway, I might go all the way
in to see where the front is, but if I'm really low and
desperate I would just go far enough that I can get some
height and build up a comfort zone before I explore further
upwind. So how far to go depends on how
comfortable you are in the task at that moment.
But turn into wind and chances are the thermal will get better.
There's exceptions to some of that, but that's that covers
most situations. It's also worth looking at that
same scenario sideways on. So going back to our thermal.
So there's our thermal there, our cloud on top.
If we're lucky, it's again you're flying along, you hit
lift, you're inside the thermal, now you've got beeps.
If you turn into wind, we're going to be closer to the core,
so hopefully going up. But if you turn the wrong way so
that you dropped out of the back, you're now In Sync, losing
air whilst you've turned to go back to the the thermal and
you're flying into wind. You get back into the thermal.
But the trouble is you didn't have to just turn the mistake.
You've got all this extra distance to get back into the
cone because you're lower the cones much further upwind.
It's why you could often feel like a real battle when you just
fall out the back. You're sinking fast and you've
also got further to go to get there.
Whereas if you make the mistake on the front come out, you
almost fall back into it. If you get lose too much height
because the cone is underneath you the thermal.
So always go upwind if you've got no other information to help
you. If you've got other gliders it's
easy, just join in with them and then scare them a bit by pushing
upwind a bit on every turn. So I tend to do when I'm with a
group of people. In my experience, majority of
pilots, even at PwC level actually, they're getting better
but they often don't push far enough at winds to explore a
little bit each turn. I sometimes explore too far.
Russell Ogden, we're quite lucky in the UK, we have a racing
Academy for our top pilots and Russell Ogden coaches us.
So next week we're all off to Saint Andre and we got a week's
coaching by him and so he gives us good tips.
He says he explores less than he used to, but it still nudged the
group upwind a little bit and it's usually better.
So that's a bit about the sideways view.
What else can we cover? Yep.
I experienced the thermos of eugilly term and month.
I better we have to say Gilly I Eugilly will lead by the birds.
Yeah, and that's in first two materials and then I decide
what's what's Silo Fern doesn't speak to me too much.
And you feel like you. Yeah.
So with wings being drawn to thermals and things, yeah.
First Sentry. Yeah, so some, some paragliders
are better than others. Some paragliders you you can
feel which side the thermal's better on and then turn into it.
Not all paragliders are very good at sensing them, but some
are very good. So if you get a chance to test
gliders, it can be good really to go out thermalling with a few
different wings you're testing and see what suits your feel to
find things hang. Gliders are the opposite, they
get pushed away from thermals. So hang gliders could be an
absolute nightmare. For those of you who are sharing
the air with the hang glider, I'll give you it from the hang
gliders perspective. It who flies hang gliders here?
Not many, but you'll know it's sometimes that paraglider's
coming to join you in the thermal or you just go into the
thermal and on the paraglider with the pendulum, it overrides
so many natural forces. You just bang into the thermal
and you yank a breakdown and off you go.
For the hang glider's perspective, he's trying to get
into a stronger part of the thermal or join the thermal and
the wing lifts and turns them away because it's a rigid wing.
And what you have to do with the hang glider is pull more speed
on and get the turn in. And sometimes it still doesn't
do it. And then you push the bar in and
out a bit to get things moving and sometimes it still doesn't
do it. And you're going along at a
horrendous rate of knots with a paraglider in front of you who's
oblivious to you. And yeah, it gets a bit scary on
a hang glider sometimes. And often you just give up and
go the other way. Or you buy an Atos.
An Atos, you just do it with a finger and you're guaranteed to
turn. But yeah, give some space to
hang gliders on weekdays. They have a hell of a time with
thermals. But yeah, paragliders, it's
often you feel it drifting. You've been drawn somewhere.
If a paraglider feels like it's just suddenly going somewhere,
go with it. It's probably been drawn to a
thermal, which I'll I can look at again in a moment a bit more.
If you lose a thermal, which way do you go to find it Upwind all
agreed. What about stable day?
Stable, Sorry, an inversion. More to the point, what about an
inverted day? So again, the textbooks, they
tend to show things like you got an inversion up there, the
thermal's rising up to there and it suddenly gets to the
inversion and it doesn't go through, especially earlier in
the day. And then the textbook likes to
show somebody with a hose pipe just squirting water at it, and
it just gradually eats away at the inversion until eventually
off it goes. But The thing is when you lose
the thermal here on that inversion layer, if you try and
fly into winds, you would definitely not find it at an
inversion layer, the thermal is downwinds.
Usually on thermaling, you lose it, you've fallen out the back.
But that's not what's happened at the inversion layer.
It's usually more that the air that's going up at 4 meters a
second here, if it's going to get through, you know the hose
pipes squirting at it, all it's doing is rising very slowly
through it. And then eventually when it gets
through your inversion layer, it might take off again.
And so you usually have to fly downwind at the inversion layer
to find that thermal because you've been busy pushing into
wind, pushing into wind, trying to find it.
Now you just got to drift downwind and it's over here the
thermal. So on on those if you know that
the air slows down 2000 meters quite significantly, just try
drifting with it and you you'll probably breakthrough sooner
then. So that's an unusual 1.
Any questions where I'm up to bit more alcohol?
What can we cover next? Ask me some questions on
thermals. I just remember something else.
Watch out. What have I got on my notes
which are destroying with alcohol?
OK, yeah, that's a good one, which I normally cover.
Do that. OK, so the wind gradient.
So again, we showed that thermal with straight lines, which I of
course said that I don't think it's like that at the back.
I think it's more like that at the back because of this air
only getting a certain distance and stopping, but the winds.
So on the ground, let's say it's blowing at one metre a second,
and up here it's blowing at 4 metres a second probably.
Zero. She could metres a second.
My Valley's got some valley with it.
It's the Alps torque, remember? I've got a valley wind but.
In this small. Burslem Air.
It's the Alps. I could feel wind on the ground.
It's an Alpine torque. I've got to go with one metre a
second here and four metres up here, just as an example of this
valley. But this air that's coming up
here that we said is rising at 4 metres a second, drifting 1,
rising at 4, drifting one. It's still doing something like
that at the top here, the same sort of angle, because it's got
a lot of mass. And so even though the wind is
strong up here, it doesn't blow off with the wind that quickly.
It doesn't get to a stage where it's going up four drifting 4 up
four drifting 4. It stays with just a 1m drift
because it has a huge mass. And if you you see all these
textbook figures that it's got this many tons or whatever in
the thermal, there's a much simpler way of visualizing it.
120 a 118 pilots all in the same start gaggle.
OK, it wasn't that classic a start gaggle of the other day.
We're weighing about whatever it is, 18 tonnes.
How much did that thermal slow down?
Not a tiny bit. That's there's so much mass in
that thermal, that air it, that wind blowing isn't really
changing, accelerating it that much.
It's carrying on with the same momentum, but it does cause
other effects around it. So we get to cloud base.
You've seen in the textbooks about climbing up the front of
the cloud. Well, where does the thermal
stop? Where's the top of the thermal
there? It's not here.
That's not where the thermal stops.
It's, it's more like this, the top of the cloud.
And again, it's I, I once had a flight back in the 90s, I took
someone for a tandem in the Pyrenees.
It's not far from here. And before we took off, she'd
never flown. She said, I want to go.
So all you want to do on the flight, you know, expecting
spirals or something, I want to go through the cloud and out the
top. It can't do that.
The thermal stop here, can't climb out the top.
And I don't mind a bit of cloud flying outside the comp.
Very off we went. We got to the cloud, so really
small things, 5000 metres deep. So I went through it and I came
out the top and kept on going. Fuck me, all the years I've been
flowing, flying, never done it. Someone asks for it and we do
it. But in principle, your top of
your thermal, somewhere at the top of the cloud, that's where
the air stopped rising and that's where we can talk about,
you know, climb up to here. Was was it an SRS?
I think it was an SRS in Jamona a year or two ago.
We had a classic one. We had layers of cloud down here
somewhere which we got past and then we kept on going and then
we were soaring up the fronts of the clouds.
And if you got round here, you were just getting flushed.
But if you're on the front, we could climb up the front and
keep on going. And we were going up to some
much horrendous heights, 34000 metres that day.
And I got there by luck because I thought I'm at cloud based,
great place to start. Couldn't see anything above me.
There was a cloud and I was sudden radio with me asking
where I was. I'm at cloud based, 2 1/2
thousand metres. No, I'm at cloud based at 3 1/2
thousand metres. And then he said just go around
the cloud, you can come some more.
So yeah, climbing up the front, but it is down to this, this
mass, this of air that's climbing up at this strong rate
and it blocks the wind. And so this wind that's coming
in starts going over the cloud. It creates like Ridge lift if
you like on the cloud. And so you can S your way up
them and get higher up on the front which then gets into cloud
flying complaints. Because there's some poor sort
over here that can't see you're in front of a cloud.
Then we start and you come out 4000 meters and he starts at
2000 meters and all he sees is you emerge from the cloud.
So that's a common way we get cloud flying complaints on the
compt people that are not really in the clouds, but from
perspective it looks like they came out.
There's also a lot of people that fly in the clouds, like the
last tasks I saw you coming out of the clouds.
So here's a mix I do recommend if you want to take advantage of
this, which is usually legal on the current version of Section
7. It briefly went banned at a
couple of years ago, but it had to become legal again.
Fly with a camera. Video camera.
Section 7 currently says Ulrich, remind me if I got it right is
something like if the if the scorer suspects you or is it
director suspects you or something, you can be
investigated and penalized. Or if a couple of pilots
complain against you, you can be penalized or whatever the other
one is. There's three ways that can
trigger you being penalized and that particular part.
Section 7 is not typical western law.
You are guilty until proven innocent, not innocent or proven
guilty. And the IT says suggested in
Section 7 that the pilot flies with a camera to prove
innocence. Even if you were clear, if you
can't prove it, you'll be penalised.
And some of you also know what me and Lisa and that we do have
a bit of a reputation for investigating cloud flying and
penalising. I think my most interesting one
was the Freedom Open 2 three years ago.
We penalised A5 hour investigation, we put the time
in five hours. We penalised about I can't
really have 1516 pilots who were all completely adamant they
weren't in the cloud and when they eventually realised the
next day I wasn't going to back down on the penalty.
One of them just comes up to the air.
We were in the cloud, really was trying to get out of it, didn't
think you could prove it. So so yeah, it happens.
I do like to stop it because it's not safe in the sport.
There's too many of you in there.
It's not safe. So and it's not sporting
obviously is the other reason the people gaining the extra 50
metres yesterday, yesterday, that was it yesterday before you
say that was a good advantage on that particular cloud catasque.
So watch out for it. Anyway, I'm going off of the
thermals here. So that's, that's a nice effect
there and why it blocks and the other beauty of it blocking,
pushing into wind as we were, if you could get in line with a
thermal, so if you saw people thermalling, it was good to get
exactly down wind of them. The thermal can block and you
could help you progress towards that thermal.
Then the winds, the air has been pushed, not just over, it's only
been pushed over near the top. The rest is being pushed around
and you can get a little bit shielded as you approach it.
So that's another good one to get into wind.
When in the pad vents we predicted also so you can share
the terminal, so you call the pre terminal whereas a bit of
windowy or thought this dumbless more or less stationary and.
So that's why I start all of this.
What? Well, this is an Alpine torque.
I live in the Alps. I don't know how to fly in
Spain. Yeah, I sort of generally I
understand then, but I tend not to go too much on that.
The UK has also its effects. We tend to fly bubbles in the
UK. So you just get up to a cloud
and then you don't bother flying downwind to next cloud.
You just stay under your cloud and drift with it until you've
got as far as you want or more commonly actually with cloud
streets and we fly the cloud streets.
So that'd be one effects, I'm guessing that that particular
one the thermal upwind is in thermal.
It's probably more to do with that shielding effect again and
you've reduced the wind strength upwind and downwind, which
allows the source to build more to then let a thermal triggering
upwind as a guess. I don't.
I haven't built a big enough picture.
Play down. Or downwinds again and.
Then you get in, oh, it's yeah, you struggle like for 10 minutes
and how did you working? And they play further down and
they get. The yeah, I'm only guessing, but
I would say it's probably think related in the theory of leaside
thermals. So you've got all this wind
blowing and it's destroyed with the hills rather than your
thing, but you've got all this wind blowing, really strong
wind. So the what did we get up to the
other day? I was on full bar doing 20 KMH.
So I guess we had a 40 KMH wind, 30 KMH wind, strong winds
anyway. And the wind is so strong that
even though you've got your triggers, the sources don't have
time to build up any warm air. They're just constantly being
broken and the air's releasing. And so flying as you would like,
a source here under a trigger here on a light wind day, that's
great, the thermal's coming out of here.
But if the wind gets too much, well that ain't going to work
because that source never builds up.
So you're actually looking for the source to be behind and then
triggering out from behind. So Lee side thermals with a Lee
side thermal calm air, it gets much, much, much hotter before
it releases. So possibly that one's a little
bit like you got a thermal blocking here, which allows less
wind strength. So the the ground behind can get
hotter again because it's less wind and build up more strength.
And then you can end up with a chain of it would be my picture
on that without experiencing it. So leaside thermals when it's
sheltered for the wind, it can get hotter, build up more before
it releases. So they're they're interesting
ones to go for leaside thermals, though they come with other
dangers. Turbulence, they're hotter.
It goes back to if you like that first source we was talking
about with all the different temperatures inside it.
And I'm sure you know, a place like Columbia give really good
examples. When we fly in Columbia, it's
got all this classic stuff in there of differentials in the
ground, tiny little triggers everywhere, plenty of sun.
We get some really good sources, really good triggers off the
thermals go. And you know, generally with our
4 meter 5m thermals out of place like that, if you arrive at 500
meters, you hook in and you've got a beautiful smooth 3M a
second thermal all the way back to base.
But if you take these things low 100 meters off the ground,
they're turbulent. You're getting rattled around a
lot. It's still that mixing air.
It hasn't separated yet, so the hot stuff's trying to push
through the knots of hot stuff that's rising, and they're just
shoving their way past each other as they get going.
All the hot stuff goes up together, all the cooler stuff
goes together. Further downwinds, the
temperatures get separated at a nice gradient, but low down
they're all shoving past each other, trying to get the path
they want. And so we get the turbulence low
down and the Lee side thermal's even worse because if your nice
thermals are leaving your ground at 4°, whatever it is, fourth
meters a second, your Lee side 1 might be doing 8 degrees, 8
meters a second. So it's even more turbulent as
it's leaving. But once you get away, they're
the best ones, but they are turbulent.
Be very careful Lee side thermals trying to capture Lee
side thermal when you're low it. Was the top of the mass of the
air. It takes 200 meters usually for
the mass to. Accelerate.
Yeah, I don't know your thought on that.
But yeah, with that big mass, it takes time to get his momentum
going. You should be in low.
And that's what's pushing through the inversion ultimately
is it keeps battering away with that momentum and so they can
get his breakthrough it properly.
There's a brief hand there. He had a big point it.
Was this side down? I was in the gumball now and.
Yeah, it's always different when you're teaching low airtime
pilots. It's just basically don't go
near lease sides to avoid the lease side always.
But when you start racing and what we're doing, if you want to
catch up the lead gaggle, take a lease side thermal.
But that's up to you. You know where your skill level
is. You need to judge the ground and
which lease side thermals. But yeah, lease sides will be
stronger, typically the thermals, but it goes nicely
into the next one. But I'll do that question the
first before I go into it of how close can you go behind an
object before it's turbulent. So I'll give you a theory on
that in a second. But what was the question?
So you know you you did a sight tool and super turbu.
So sushi did that massive still, What's a say these options?
Just you go to your Paisley? Did you get simple inlet tool?
Was it this? This also could be.
It's it's one of those that when you get start playing with those
thermals, it's down to your experience and how much you know
you're weighing and everything else.
With weather, you can never give a hard and fast rule of what to
do. But yeah, when on a thermal,
anytime you just try to get that hoop going on the strong part of
the thermal and just get a constant rate going.
Everything got to be smooth, smooth flowing to get the best
climb. So yeah, what to do?
I don't know, it's a hard question to answer really on
that. But what I can do is give a
picture of when what you can go behind and what you can't.
So we know landing in the Lee of a building or a set of trees has
a high chance of a collapse. So this 20m tree landing just
downwind of it, you've got a high chance to take the collapse
in that. So what?
So when can we go behind an object?
If a 20m tree is not safe, why do we think going behind
mountains are safe? They're much bigger.
So why aren't we getting problems on those?
Tenerife, you're flying in the Lee of the of the mountain all
the time. It's the only place to fly is in
the Lee. So it's when is the Lee safe and
when it's not? Well, again, it's weather.
There's no definite hard rule. But if you take a mountain that
stick it up in the wind, my rule usually is the danger zone is
something like 100 meters deep somewhere around there.
That's the area I'm really scared of for going.
Depends on the wind strength, but certainly a kilometre, that
whole 100 metre deep, one kilometre zone for me is the
most dangerous place to be on it.
If I'm down here, it's probably very sheltered and calm.
So I can land in this area and we're talking a significant
thing, a 500 meters tall or something.
I could be landing down here, it's blocking the wind, but here
the wind is blowing over it and bubbling behind it.
And where's the least side thermal going to be with this
strong winds on this side? So nothing's forming and the
sun's blowing, shining on the other side.
It's going to be building up the heat here and releasing here.
And it might be drawing some air up that way.
So on top, it's a nice release and it's coming from behind, but
I wouldn't go into that zone to take it.
It's just that's a significant area.
The 100 meters deep trees, 20m tall buildings are 50 meters
tall. You don't go behind them and see
at least a kilometre, say downwind.
So again, you you got to look at every scenario, every shape to
side, but just be aware if you're in that type of area.
What a cash flow below your leisure and you.
Actually, don't climb out. Below your leisure.
So if it's coming from a source here, you mean you start
climbing out with it here again, every situation is different,
but probably when I'm in the thermal it has that mass to
protect me from the wind, so I can climb out with it whilst I'm
within the bubble. Just don't fall out your bubble.
So there's that one. What was I going to roll onto?
I forget still. Be pretty messy.
Oh yeah, still be messy. So yeah, make sure you've got
your echo and skills ready. Have a chat with Cesar and that
does probably roll into SIV as well.
So who's not done SIV here yet? I, I won't kick you out the comp
despite the rules. No one's admitting to it.
OK, someone did actually on the the feedback list.
I think a few comps back they hadn't done SIV.
It's like, well, it's kind of in the rules.
So this rule this year we have on the rules you, you must have
done had SIV experience. So we don't put time limits on
it. But SIV experience is pretty
key. I don't think you need to be
personally, I don't think you need to be super experienced in
stalls or anything, but you do need to be experienced in
capturing the dive, for example. So you probably know it's pretty
much the first exercise on SIV. Of course you're done.
You get into a bit of a spiral and you come out and the wing
goes back. Miles shoots forward and he
taught to catch it because that will teach you probably half of
what you need to stay safe clearing cravats.
But we don't actually do cravats on SIV.
Usually we just go through the motions of clearing the cravats,
which is how to pump it out. It's not this, it's, you know,
pump this thing out sharp. Quick note, hold down there, you
get up. You should hopefully all done
this on courses. So yeah, clear the cravats, but
the more skills you have in that, the more you can think
about playing with this. But don't go diving in this
unless you've got the skills for the ruffster.
It is going to be rough behind there, so it should.
Be fine as up a wise sync. You know they get Freelander for
spirits to get out there. So if you're In Sync, heavy
sync, depends where you are in that whole thermal chain.
Again, if it's synced because I've just left at base and we're
heading towards the next turn point.
The the first rules on that would be don't follow the person
directly in front of you. Spread out a little, not far, 10
metres the side of them and hopefully someone else will be
10 metres the side. You just spread out a little
because then you'll see some of you will get a better line than
others and then you just turn 45° and join the ones doing
better. If I'm on the own a little bit
and I've got sync on that transition, turn 45°, go to the
side a little because you'll be amazed how sometimes you just
keep on going. You're in 3 or 4 meters and you
just try and push the bar harder and it just never ending.
Just turn 45°, you probably only have to go for your 40 meters
and suddenly you've got the floating line.
There was definitely a notable one on the task the other day.
Myself and another GTO, we left, we were together thermally and
we left and we went slightly different lines.
And he was only 20 meters off from me in front of me without
an SRS mirror. And by the time we'd gone 2
kilometers, he was 300 meters lower than me.
So keep an eye on people around you.
Just turn a little so that that's the transition scenario.
It could also be these thermals again, where you're trying to
push into wind and you're just behind this thing, you're trying
to push in into winter to catch the thermal, but you're sliding
underneath this cone and then it's in the weak stuff.
You, you can slide all the way down trying to get to where the
core is. Whereas if you fly downwind, you
the place you, if you started here and that distance is a
kilometre, the place you actually hit it might only be
800 metres away. You haven't got far to fly if
you fly in downwind. Whereas here, if you kilometre
away from the back of the thermal, it might take you 2
kilometres to get into it still because it's so much further
away the place you're going to into the thermal.
So in those cases, hard to know what to do, but try.
And that's where I said earlier, if you see people thermally
upwinder view, try and get in line with the thermal.
So it's directly upwind. I'll be a little bit sheltered
by it just to push there easier. But yeah, it's it's too many
situations where you might be In Sync.
You have to try and identify what's causing it and how can I
get a better line as a result to get out of it.
And if you're low, really low that you might have the
possibility of bomb if the situation allows.
It's often just get hunting downwind.
You can cross a lot of terrain downwind very quickly to try and
find what's triggering. Just forcing and forcing and
forcing into wind. You just got to deck yourself.
Even cross wind is better than into wind in that scenario.
Let's jump in a different part of it all, because we don't just
have thermals to take lift. Living in Slovenia is quite nice
because all we've really got is ridges.
So we do a lot of Ridge flying in there.
You know, I was lucky enough I set a few world records on
tandem flying out and returns, but it's just a Ridge run.
SO220K100170 KS out, hundred and something KS back.
Follow the Ridge in principle. So ridges which I can't draw
easily in 2D, but you've got the valley floor here and you've got
the top of the Ridge. Let's do something like that.
So those who know it in Slovenia, this is the Stole
Ridge. We've got a launch up here.
We've got the border to Italy over here and cobbered over
here. So looking on it, you've got a
Ridge that just gently climbs and the wind usually blows that
way. It's a West wind if you're on a
flying day usually. So when you're coming into
ridges. As a general rule, and there's
all lots of receptions, but as a general rule, I want to try and
stay in that band to fly the Ridge.
So you know, the top 10% of it or just above it is where the
best lift is. The air is coming in on the
Ridge itself. It's usually destroyed, drawn
up, so the valley winds coming down as it hits the Ridge, it
gets drawn up the Ridge and then it's releasing somewhere on the
top. But if you get too low down,
there's not much wind and it's the climb rates are slow.
As it gets up, it all gathers and accelerates and that zone is
where the the Ridge. The best lift is and we're on a
Ridge. Then you don't need to stop so
much. You don't have to come along and
there'll be good points on this Ridge.
There's usually up this area around the launch.
There's usually a very good thermal up here and this area,
because of how the train's working, there's usually a good
thermal around there. But when I'm flying that Ridge,
when I connect to it, I won't fly to here and I go, ah, good
thermal up to the cloud and off I go.
Because all I would do is waste time climbing.
Then I'll leave the climb and I'll be in very sinky air until
I land back on the Ridge again. And all I've done is just waste
5 minutes climbing. And the person who was with me,
he just carried on in This Ridge lift is much further up.
So on a good Ridge, don't waste time climbing.
But remember you need to stay in the top.
It's not unusual to connect onto the stall Ridge and then you
just keep flying and you know you're sinking at one metre a
second. You need one metre a second
climb air to stay up. And it's not that strong at the
start, maybe it's only half a metre a second.
So people fly along the Ridge hoping to climb out and they
just get to a stage where they just drop too low on the Ridge,
All their mates are up here on top flying along it and they're
trying to keep up. And you just end up below this
10% rule I like, and then you just sink out very quickly.
So you sometimes got to take time to come back and zigzag to
get back on top and then push on and then zigzag back on top and
then push on. If you'd be just above, it's a
very good chance you can run the whole Ridge without stopping.
And you have to get above the Ridge for to do that.
And As for these thermals, maybe if the wind's too much, I'll
climb a little bit of it, but just so I can land here on it.
But I definitely do not climb all the way to base on a Ridge.
Use the Ridge itself to fly faster.
Every turn. You're doing a thermal for half
of it. You're going in the wrong
direction for the next turn point.
So if I just keep pushing, it's faster.
How long have we been going for? So many more topics, but an
hour. How's your camera doing?
We've finished his. His hammer only goes for one
hour. Let's see where I just wrote one
more interesting one. Yeah.
So they so we absolutely have actually, but they're suburb.
I saw that history. Well, I couldn't go over there
thinking there you must sign involve or we're running there
your cavities or cavities. So funny enough, that's exactly
the thing I was going to go on to, I think this next one.
So I live in a place called Soritzer.
I don't know if anyone's heard of Soritzer.
It's it's in Slovenia. A lot of you probably know
Tolman. And then you got Kern, the big
mountain, the Tolman. I live on a house that's similar
to that spine at Kern. It's just 15 KS before Kern.
But I live on top of that spine at a ski resort and there's a
lodge there called Soritzer that's only flyable about 5 or 6
days a year, properly flyable. But it the Julian alt certainly
used to, probably still does hold more world records than
anywhere else in the world. So it's just they're out on
returns, they're boring, and nobody looks at them.
And the way we set the records there is we wait for bad
weather, a local effect called a boreal winds, where we've had
high pressure N low pressure S Bad weather comes through, sets
up this wind, which is a strong northeast wind flowing through
the Alps. And then on from that, we know
that in four days at the right time of year, we might set a
world record. And it's because on that last
day, you wake up in the morning and it's an east wind going
through all the valleys, and we take off on this east winds and
we fly for 100 KS. Then in the afternoon, the
proper weather comes back and we have a West wind and we fly
downwind all the way back again. And so we get a lovely out in
return with downwinds even at both ways, even though it's out
in return. But the Ridge itself, OK, if
you've flown Tolman a lot, you know, we don't take off till
12:30. The sun's not working till then.
The winds aren't right, 12/30, 1:00, it's about the normal
launch time and off we go. But sorry, so we launched at
10:30. We can launch much, much earlier
in the day and get going even though it's only 15 KS away.
And the the reasons for it, it's high.
So it's above the inversion. All the valleys were inverted.
If you think of the mountains, we're flying off a Ridge here or
something. The inverted air, it tends to
fill up at night. It just fills from this tip to
this tip with cold air at night. All of that's your inversion
inverted air in here. But if you can take off up here,
you can be above those valleys filled with the cold air and the
thermal start sooner up here than they do in the cold valley
or the inverted valleys. So it has that advantage which
taking off just above the inversion so we can start
earlier. It's in fact the world record
days is usually so inverted in the valley that Kabbalah launch
should normally starts 1231 o'clock.
Sometimes it doesn't go until 2 much later start.
And yet we've all been flying past them at 11 AM.
They can see us flying booming along lovely conditions, but
they they take off later because it's more Infinity for them.
That's the local effect on it. But the next part of it, if
we're looking down at all of this lot, the Ridge looking down
tends to be actually a series of bowls and it's a repetitive
pattern. So we, we've got the launch
point here at Surrey, We're heading off towards Stoll in the
distance over here, whatever it is about 50 kilometres or
something. And it's just a series of bowls
that we're flying and it's you have the sun, sun's coming up on
the east, the sun's coming up on this side.
And the sun's heating up this side of the bowl all the time.
And we rely on that because we, we take off and we just fly.
Remember, it's, it's not, that's the winds up showing.
This is the east wind. The sun's in the east.
It's in east wind blowing that way.
We take off, we fly downwind to the far side of the bowl.
It's got sun on it and it's got winds blowing on it.
So we get a bit of Ridge lift, bit of sun.
We climb up on top of the Ridge, We flop over this, we fly over
the Lee side and we land on that bowl and we climb up, get high
enough, flop over, miss the light Lee side into the next
bowl. And that's just how you fly it
all morning long. Just the far sides of the bowls
are heating up and then in, in the afternoon, evening when
we're coming back, the West wind is cut in and the sun's on the
West side now, so it heats up. This side we do the same thing.
We climb up here, we flop over the leaf side and we hit that
side and fly back. But it's just knowing the time
of the day and what the sun is shining on, for what we can fly
on. And these bowls, they're on many
scales. They might be 5 kilometers long
where it might contain small bowls within it, you know, a few
100 meters. But the pattern's still the same
on every bowl. It's the pattern that counts.
If that bowl works here, that bowl will work in the same
place, and that bowl will work in the same place at the same
time of day. So I learn everything I need to
know about my day on the first bowl at that moment.
And then I apply that knowledge for what the next bowl will be
like and then what the next bowl will be like.
And it's just repeating the pattern.
And as the day changes, it's very slow because obviously I
update my model here, I update the model here, but it's about
those repetitive patterns. I think the repetitive patterns
are quite important in our sports all along.
When we was flying that task 2 days ago and you got to the
hills, you try to learn from the people in front of you,
preferably where the climb was and where it wasn't.
And then you repeat what they did and it's that repetitive
pattern. And then you sort you should be
learning that terrain, which way it faced relative to the sun,
the wind, and then repeat it on the next Ridge and the next.
So just try to repeat repetitive patterns as the day goes and
updating the model as you go. And you've always got your those
of you on the narrator. Udi's example, it's got the map
on there, the historic place, you'll find the thermals.
It's about repetitive patterns. Again, you know, that's that
farmer's field has been there for several 100 years.
So the source has been there for several 100 years.
The triggers might have changed a bit.
The pylons were only built 20 or 30 years ago, but they've been
there long enough for your mapping data to take account of
it. And we tend to fly when the wind
directions are in the same direction.
You know, the site is flyable on the east wind, but not West.
So those that's is historic information that gives you, that
gives you the model to fly and it's the same on this on a small
scale in the minutes and hours or on the big scale of the
months and time of year and so on.
So for all of it, for me really it's like everything asked for.
The more you do it, the easier it gets.
I used to hate the question on the guided trips of how did I
know there was a thermal over there?
I don't know of a subconscious wanting to go that way.
I didn't realise I did go over there.
I just went that way because I felt like it and climbed.
That's training the subconscious from the repetitive models or
the repetitive actions or the the acro.
He was talking about building up the muscle memory.
It's putting things in the subconscious because your
subconscious is doing 100 times more work than your conscious.
Maybe an example of that is when you passed your driving test,
you spent your whole first day trying to stay between 2 white
lines because your conscious is driving.
Now all these years later, you drove to Spain and you don't
even remember the highway because your subconscious drove
you here, not your conscious, your conscious just went.
I've got to turn off at that exit or I need some fuel.
That's all the conscious did. Your subconscious did all the
other stuff. So the more you fly, the more
you repeat patterns, the more you do it all, the less you
think, or the more you do the SIV, the less your conscious
thinks and the more capacity your brain has then to adapt to
the new stuff. More the conscious to focus on
things that are actually making the difference for winning the
day. If that all makes sense.
I think that place along is like very, but the there of your
sorts is about yeah, like flying off and just looking down, just
getting in subconscious impressions how it looks at the
one fine areas. It's probably over there.
I don't know why, it's probably. Over there.
Yeah, exactly. I mean, I it's very hard for me
in the early days guiding with guiding, you're supposed to
teach the people and I'm not very good at just working it
out. I have to build up mental
pictures to help me. So it is just repetitive.
But then it's when you're doing it repetitive, try and
understand why your subconscious did that because it might help
me with the next level then. So there you go.
I've got tons of other stuff we could probably throw in, but
that's probably enough to, if you list, find that talk online
if you want some more. I definitely had other stuff in
there I threw in as well, but there you go.
Don't know how much it'll help you tomorrow, but fingers
crossed for tomorrow.